an airstrike in the capital of
ethiopia's tigray region could signal a
new phase of renewed fighting
local media say the central government
is responsible for the attack in an area
controlled by rebels from the tigrayan
people's liberation front or tplf
i think the airstrike hit around noon a
neighborhood is a residential area so
only civilians live here
the fighting which began earlier this
week marks the end of a ceasefire that
was agreed to in march
it also derails efforts to negotiate a
peace deal between prime minister abi
ahmed's government and tplf fighters
it's important to have some insight
about why this war presumed right now
tigray was under effective siege
receiving
no fuel no electricity no communication
no
banking the drive forces are at their
weakest point right now
the fighting has made an already dire
humanitarian crisis worse millions of
people have been displaced with more
than three thousand reportedly fleeing
from the region every day
the un and other aid agencies have been
able to deliver some made in the past
few months
earlier this week the head of the world
food program accused tplf fighters of
stealing food and more than 500 000
liters of fuel
humanitarian aid meant for civilians
never reached its target
all the parties need to do whatever they
can to protect uh to protect civilians
and also very importantly i think to
ensure the unimpeded passage of
humanitarian uh goods
the latest round of violence is raising
concerns that could put even more people
at risk in tigray and the surrounding
amhara and afar regions
katya lopez of the young al jazeera